yes we're outside of harbor ucla medical
center where
we did hear from medical personnel
inside that tiger woods
is still undergoing surgery on his legs
after that
really terrible looking crash this
morning we saw the vehicle with the
crush damage to the front and the
intrusion
into the front compartment of the car we
do know that he was alert and talking to
the first responders who were able to
get him out of the wreckage and into the
ambulance and off to the hospital but he
has been in surgery
now for several hours we know that he
was in town over the weekend for the
genesis
invitational golf charge was
where he was the host and he'd been
talking about getting back out on the
golf course and being able to come back
and
start playing in the masters starting
in uh on april 8th i believe is the date
where the masters was supposed to start
but he had just had a back surgery and
was hopeful that he'd be able to come
back and
and be ready to play by then but he was
still having a little bit of stiffness
now all those plans thrown to the wind
as this accident happened this morning
and put him back in the hospital with
more surgery
and trauma to his legs is what we're
told